100% of customers are people and 100% of
clients are people and 100% of employees
are people I don't care how good your
product is I don't care how good your
marketing is I don't care how good your
design is if you don't understand people
you don't understand business we are
social animals we are human beings and
our survival depends on our ability to
form trusting relationships
do you ever watch Deadliest Catch I'm a
Discovery Channel i sling two channels
one night and Deadliest Catch came on
and on this episode just random they
were in a huge storm now for those of
you who don't know Deadliest Catch they
take these crab fishing boats out on the
Bering Sea which is like terrible and
they put cameras on them and we watch
right the reason that's I guess
significant is because these crab
fishermen have I think one of the top 5
deadliest jobs in the world you know I
don't know what the exact number is but
dozens of fishermen die every year doing
doing this we apparently find that
entertaining which is actually they have
cameras only on five or six of the ships
even though there are many many me ships
that go out fishing every season and
they don't really come into proximity
with each other because you know the
oceans huge and they usually sabotage
each other and give each other false
information because they're all
competitors they're all looking to get
the crabs and you know make sure that
they find them somebody else doesn't and
it's business right it's just business
that's okay we all do the same thing in
our own company and in this one episode
this big huge storm was so violent that
they had to bring all the pots which are
the big cages that they catch the crabs
in they they bring will the pot back on
the boat
and wait out the storm and just by dumb
luck one of the boats that had cameras
on it was in proximity of a boat that
didn't have cameras on and so they
filmed they had secured all their pots
on the deck and so they started filming
the other boats and they filmed a guy
climbing on the outside of the cage
securing the pot
and all of a sudden a huge wave hits the
side of the boat and the guy's not there
anymore and the people on the boat with
the camera starts screaming Man
Overboard Man Overboard Man Overboard
and they turned their boat towards where
they think he might be he's a stranger
they don't know him they don't know the
crew members of the other boat and yet
they react and they turned towards him
and they find him in the drink
and for those of you don't understand
how dangerous this is if the water is so
cold that you're in the water for I
think that it's a minute or a minute
thirty hypothermia will set him in you
die and they come upon him and he's
screaming don't let me die don't let me
die and they pull him on board not out
of the woods yet he strip off his
clothes because it's wet and cold and
they wrapped blankets around him to
prevent hyperthermia from setting it and
he survives and it's overwhelming and
the captain comes down and this is all
on me you can go watch it on TV the
camera comes the captain comes down and
he hugs this stranger this young man his
competitor he hugs this guy's if he's
his own son I lost it everybody is
crying and you realize what happened
here was a human interaction and the
reason they risked their own lives to
help this other person even though they
spend every other day trying to get
ahead and sabotage is because at the end
of the day they're all crab fishermen
and they know something about each other
and they know something about the risk
that they all take to do this and when
push comes to shove they will put
themselves out there to help each other
for no other reason than they get it
there one of the same I will promise you
that every single member of that crew
that day went home with a feeling of
fulfillment I promise you it's every
single person on that crew that day felt
more good in their hearts and in their
jobs than the richest day that they've
ever
moving my question is is what are you
doing to help the person next to you
don't you want to wake up and go to work
for the only reason that you can do
something good for someone else when you
want them to do that for you
[Music]